Santa Monica
[__] I'm still only in Santa Monica
every morning I think I'm going to wake
up back in Indonesia or Myanmar or
Mexico
I lived out of two bags for three years
no fixed address
no fixed anything
I hid under tarps to sneak across
borders
I tiptoed through minefields
hitched rides on U.N Peacekeeper
Choppers
now I've been domesticated
my language skills have frayed my
intestinal bacteria is no longer feral
even my stubborn insomnia has been
fading
I eat better I think clearer
but I can't help but think I'm getting
weaker
softer
I am more fragile
there is no doubt that I've lost
something essential to who I am
everyone gets everything they want
and I wanted a mission
and for my sins Rich gave me one
which is how I decided to bring my whole
family down to a remote corner of Mexico
to a coastline where climate change and
natural disaster
migration and crime have hammered the
landscape
the economy and the people who live
there
what is happening
Adam
what what
Creative Flair I don't know how the Rich
Roll podcast suddenly got commandeered
and turned into the Adam skolnik travel
Radio Hour
[Music]
you know the the uh the bougie version
of you know Apocalypse Now yes yes well
thank you for indulging me but listeners
this is the Rich Roll podcast
[Music]
2.0 where we dive into a topic from
different angles and this month that
topic is regenerative travel
you love travel I do you're the travel
guy
right right your career path it was it
was I was uh for the better part of nine
years my main income was lonely planet
travel guide so I was on the road nine
months a year every year all over the
place and and uh I really that was kind
of how you would I felt like it defined
me really that that's what I did I
didn't have a normal life I didn't have
a lot of stuff that I have now for sure
um my back door was out into the whole
world right um yeah certainly I'm
somebody who who loves travel I look
forward to travel it's always something
that you know kind of gets me out of the
bed out of bed excited about what's to
come and I think most people love travel
but here we are in 2023
and I think collectively and
individually we're all grappling with
you know how to be better citizens how
to be more environmentally conscious
about our choices how we spend our time
how we allocate our resources and travel
kind of presents a problem it's sort of
an elephant in the room something we
don't
exactly want to acknowledge or confront
head on because it's uncomfortable
knowing that that Wanderlust or that
vacation that you've been saving up for
or that thing on the calendar that
you've been so looking forward to has
negative consequences for the planet
so that's what we're going to do today
we're going to talk about it and we're
going to do that
through the lens of a question and the
question is
is it possible to travel in a completely
sustainable way and if so how and if not
what is the best way to move about the
globe 100
um one thing I never ever once
considered was my carbon footprint I
never once considered the environmental
aspect of it not one time and I'm an
environmentalist it's something I care
about a lot and I'm not one time that I
think that this is unsustainable this is
there is a cost to this that I'm not
acknowledging so which I think really
underscores that elephant in the room
thing absolutely not only do we not want
to look at it we don't it doesn't even
occur to us but then we have people like
Greta who appear who decide the only way
to get to the United States is by
sailboat right right and then we all
just sort of descend into you know guilt
and shame over our own choices and the
solution can't be in in you know
martyrdom or just isolationism either
right like I think that as a collective
we need to find Productive solutions
that incentivize travel but do it with
systems that are are
incentivizing and and kind of
um you know provoking regenerative
Solutions along the way is part and
parcel of that process yeah we're very
far away from that right now but I think
it's important to talk about it and to
kind of explore what those Solutions
might look like what currently exists
and what might exist with a little bit
more imagination political Civic and
economic will I love it and and so I
believe we're going to start with the
benefits of travel like what's great
about travel
you know I think through escaping our
mundane are we able to to expand our
awareness and our Consciousness it opens
up your brain to new possibilities
um I also think that it makes you more
accepting
um of other people and cultures it's a
way to understand and to to see that our
tools it's it's very different uh
depending the perspective that you see
it uh when you go to to other countries
you visit other cultures uh you you
discover that what you had believed for
all your life like uh it has different
angles and that's that's key for for
progress
it's really it's an expansion of the
heart and mind right that that that
happens when you have these big
experiences
I mean
incredibly broadening experience I've
been to Beirut twice I've been to
Bahrain I've been to three cities in
Saudi Arabia and and those experiences
really changed me and and broadened my
perspective on
um on the world and and on humanity and
how to interface with Humanity we all
have lots of you know kind of
preconceived judgments and ideas about
how people live on the other side of the
world uh and it and until you travel
there and sit in living rooms and
convene with people in in analog
one-on-one format
um you can't truly understand
the similarities and the differences uh
the things that separate us and the
things that unite us without that yeah
right so it it holds a you know a place
of great value for me and I think a
great value in general
um in terms of the education proposition
of travel you know I became a writer
because I wanted to write my my way
around the world that was always the
goal and for me that's because what I
found
in myself my own life but also I see it
is that
in our daily lives especially in the
modern in modern world that we live in
and I think it's even worse now with the
phones we are basically like wrapped in
this like cellophane
um our feelings become dominant because
there's no place for it to breathe and
you are who you are you're fixed in this
world and you know you're you're where
you live so well
that you kind of can move like a shark
through it
and for me what I found with the best
trips I'm not saying all trips are like
this but the ones where you really
immerse yourself
are like poking a hole in that
cellophane and ripping it open so that
you are exposed to the world and so when
that happens you do come back
there's something that happens that
expands your your awareness of who you
are and a connection to everyone and
everything because that Oneness is real
like what you experienced in the Middle
East or in the Arab world or whatever
um that to me is what's so powerful
about it and that's why you know tourism
is a huge market right let's let's face
it like as we talk about there's impacts
but there's also benefits I mean in 2019
before the pandemic 10.4 percent of the
global GDP that's 9.2 trillion dollars
was because of travel and tourism that's
tourism Market I mean that's huge 10.6
of all jobs
in the whole world 334 million jobs is
related to tourism and travel
um visitor spending here in the United
States 1.7 trillion in 2019. now the
covid pandemic happened and things
really declined like a 50 decline or
more in some places many millions of
jobs were lost
um but what happened when kovid was kind
of getting toward where we decided that
we were opening up again is we saw this
Revenge travel element so you know it
started to bounce back so there are
positive aspects of travel I think we we
don't want to overlook right so travel
generates money it generates jobs it
generates economic growth these are all
good things of course
however
and the United Nations has released a
key report on climate change we need a
Quantum Leap in climate action to combat
what we've done just one round trip
transatlantic flight emits twice as much
carbon dioxide emissions as driving the
family car for an entire year this week
alone more than 90 thousand people came
to Hawaii
crease so does the amount of garbage
found along our shorelines these popular
stops are sacred I hope it's awesome so
it's us that we need to do more to save
this 100 sad yeah
[Music]
so obviously there are environmental
costs baked into every trip that we take
and it's we got to reckon with them and
one is the carbon footprint right that's
the most obvious one one of the ways to
address the carbon footprint is through
this thing called carbon offsets but
what are carbon offsets and are they
really effective
there's a hundred thousand flights a day
I don't know if you know that stat but
like every single day around the world
there are a hundred thousand flights
this is Paul Feinstein prolific travel
writer and author of Voters travel
guides and I think that accounts for
maybe the same amount of pollution that
all the cars account for like it's an
insane amount of environmental
degradation I hate everything about it I
hate this idea of carbon credit of
carbon credits I think it's [__]
because it's like it's like saying oh we
can be as polluting as we want over here
because we're doing all this good stuff
over here you're not really solving any
problem you're still you're still a
problem
I've I've checked out a number of these
offset options it's cheap yeah the thing
is like is this green washing just to
make us feel better about like jumping
on flights here and there or is that
really making a difference like that's
something I don't know the answer to
right and I think it depends you know
the the the pro publica did uh a deep
dive into this one market and how
basically these these contributions were
supposed to be preserving and then
reforesting an area and it wasn't
working now to offset a six hour flight
it's like 12 bucks if it's coach it's
like 12 bucks so it's like you look at
that and you think
how will that be right well you're right
if you look at if you look at the cost
of the carbon the amount of people on a
plane how long that flight is that's
what that's what it comes that's how
they break it down twelve dollars I saw
it actually priced it just under four
dollars as well but if you look at
twelve dollars is like that bottom line
that's so easy like you think well if I
wish this this was 100 it worked because
it's an easy it's an easy give bottom
line is we don't know if the offset
thing is productive is working as
especially if you if you're funneling
your your money to these organizations
online that you've never heard about and
there's just nothing there like the
organic label that we can trust yet
there isn't there isn't some kind of
Clearinghouse or or place to go where we
can say these are the ones that are
doing it right right not that I'm aware
of I mean there's some that that claim
to do it right but I think this
pro-publica story
um which will link up in the show yeah
yeah it shows that that's there's an
argument there that that maybe it's not
working out the problem is that
restoration is kind kind of complicated
and not every tree you plant is going to
survive and like you know it's
complicated and it's hard to do and and
um and there's politics in every region
that you might want to do it in so it's
like the question is is that ever really
a solution or is the solution what kind
of Killian came up with right so it's
one thing to give lip service to how we
think about travel and our environmental
responsibility and it's another thing to
actually like walk the walk right and
somebody who's walking the walk in a
really in inspirational way is a friend
of the podcast
and perhaps the greatest living
endurance athlete our friend Killian
jornay
uh but then as athletes of course it's
it's all about traveling and then it's
it's all about
moving because races are all over the
world like uh if you went to the
adventures projects and we have the
opportunity and I think for me the
biggest difference it's been like before
I was taking it for granted like okay I
can go to raising in Malaysia in Japan
in U.S in in Australia in South Africa
in a single year so I was taking this as
something that granted because I was an
athlete
well today I think it's
it's uh it's precious like to to travel
it means that uh that I will have a
footprint so uh if I do it it needs to
be something very very special so I
think in the last years that's what we
have changed the most for me is to to
change my way of thinking that I'm doing
it I'm traveling because I can
to I travel as something that uh
I know the the harm of it and I take it
as a something precious and knowing that
more deeply like of course like I have
been seeing like glaciers disappearing
all my whole life and and see these
effects like all the time but to connect
that to
to my daily actions like uh it took a
period of time so um I would say I
still like a big footprint but I try to
limit my international travel to to once
a year and then try to to do the other
in so I can like use low emission means
to you to go to the races
so mad respect for Killian for you know
basically taking such a hard line and
and and being so intentional about how
he
is thinking about his travel yeah that's
a guy who probably could be traveling
all the time and going to amazing places
and doing all these races and he's like
no I'm not doing that like that's
[__] badass it is it is to do that
um
and I think that it's inspiring for the
rest of us that leads us all to be a
little bit more Mindful and and
conscientious like when I'm thinking
about like buying that next airplane
ticket I'm gonna be thinking about would
kill me and do that right and he would
probably say no right so I'm gonna think
twice you know I don't know the answer
to that question I like what killing had
to say though like if you limit it to
one trip one big trip if that's the way
you look at things
that makes a lot of sense actually and
you you're mindful of where you're going
how long you're going for maybe do that
trip make that a longer trip I mean
that's that's kind of a guiding post for
me I'm starting to see and and think the
same way you are the way Killian is
doing it because it makes it makes a lot
of sense he's not just like he's
obviously thought it out and it makes a
lot of sense right what about hotels
yeah hotels are a mixed bag because if
you look at them
um when you're when you have a hotel in
a remote location sometimes depending on
the level of invest of investment that
will sometimes necessitate and include
sewage treatment
alternative energy sources Landscaping
sometimes natural Landscaping so not all
Hotel developments is created equal
basically the word sustainable is a
buzzword and there's no such thing in
the hotel world so uh there are hotels
that try very very hard in a lot of
different ways and there are hotels that
are being performative once again this
is Paul Feinstein so when I say
performative you'll see hotels saying oh
you know we use a specific kind of light
bulb and we got rid of single-use
plastics and and so on and so forth but
then like maybe you're at a hotel in
Norway and they have mangoes on the menu
well you know what don't grow in Norway
mangoes and so to get a mango in Norway
It's gotta go on a tanker and it has to
go a very far distance and it's the
least sustainable thing you could
possibly do
like I haven't seen a hotel figure out
laundry yet laundry is the most there's
the least sustainable thing in a hotel
it abuses water it uses chemicals it
there's a ton of waste uh the energy it
takes to run it is prohibitive
um so yeah I'm seeing some hotels that
are really fascinating you know they
have their own farms and they have you
know they grow their own produce and and
their own eggs in their own Dairy and
but you know if it's a five-star
location you really have to educate your
guests properly because if that guest
wants this thing they're going to do it
they're going to go out of their way to
get it and I don't know it's just really
hard like a hotel
you know inherently is not a sustainable
operation so you know it really depends
on the ownership group to really focus
on things that are not just performative
like single-use plastic
well there's also two other interesting
ripples here and a lot of kind of uh you
know tourist destination towns during
the pandemic a lot of higher net worth
people bought up real estate or second
homes in these locations to flee their
you know kind of urban primary homes
yeah and that has gone a long way
towards you know driving the cost of
living and the cost of housing up such
that the support staff can't afford to
live in the locations that serve all of
these people right so ski towns Etc
um and that has created a really
unsustainable situation economically
um and it's almost you know kind of like
a
human rights issue right like if you
can't if you can't have a community
where the people that that basically you
know allow the infrastructure to exist
they can't live there what does that say
about your priorities and the long-term
viability or or health of that community
at large and that's that's that's a huge
issue and then the second Ripple being
the impact that the rise of of social
media has had yeah on on driving Trends
in travel where you know such a premium
uh is placed on you know getting that
perfect shot or that selfie or that
making that real in that exotic location
and how that's driving
um consumer Behavior Uh to kind of maybe
travel more than one ordinarily should
for the purpose of uh content creation
and you know external validation and
like brand building yeah it's exactly
right and you know I even talked to
Celeste Brash a fellow writer for lonely
planets I'm a colleague of mine back
when I was doing the Lonely Planet books
I should say you know she and I spoke
for a while about this concept exactly
I have felt that a lot of the shift in
travel has been less of
um
you know seeing a country of more like
what is there to do in a country rather
than what can I learn from a country and
I feel like travel has gotten a lot less
expensive so it's got It's become open
to a wider range of people and it's also
become sort of a cool thing to do in
Instagram especially obviously is you
know people showing the photos of them
in these places and going in to places
just for the gram and all of that
I it it's really changed the type of
traveler like now I see people who are
who are really there it's a very
self-centered activity where I feel like
when I started traveling and sort of up
until now you know my parents Generation
[Music]
Um in the 60s and 70s and all of that
um you know people were really going to
sort of find experiences and meet the
people and see different things and see
different cultures and there are
certainly people who are still doing
that quite a few but I feel like
bulk of Travelers nowadays or are going
it's all about what is there to do like
that's what all of my writing guidebooks
everything now has shifted to
you know not a guide of how to find out
things on your own it's a guide of
telling you what there is to do what you
can do to have fun sort of it's it feels
exploited exploitative to me
so Hugh Garvey who is now the
editor-in-chief of Sunset magazine was
my editor at Playboy and Hugh was the
first person that kind of brought to me
this concept that travel was broken this
is like in 2015 and his whole thing was
everything's the same everywhere it's
all [__] boring and so I had to I had
to call him I had to call Hugh and and
talk about this particular issue because
you know I know he was early on on the
Travel is broken but also because as the
editor of sunset he is you know helping
readers find their way to an authentic
experience in the in the American West
travel has always been broken you know
basically the the vacation was you know
an invention of the I believe you know
uh late 19th century you know at
post-industrial Revolution people with
time on their hands and then people who
wanted to make money off of people with
time on their hands and
um so you know fast forward to today uh
we all can travel for relatively
um cheap uh from a financial perspective
but uh at extreme cost to the planet
um and you know we're such novelty
Seekers now both um virtually and in
real life and uh it's almost too easy to
go anywhere
okay all of that said Adam then why did
you embark on this Mexico trip what was
it about this location that captured you
and what did you learn through the
process
you know it's this notion of
regeneration
and could that which we've seen in
agriculture and is now kind of migrating
to travel in that space can that address
some of these issues that have made
travel I guess somewhat broken hmm
so when I hear that word regeneration
first I want to understand what you mean
by that and also I can't help but think
is this just a marketing catchphrase
that's been diluted and thrown around
just a lure tourists into you know
traveling to some place uh under the
auspices of of doing good for the world
when in truth it's nothing more than
just you know business as usual okay
well I can Define regeneration for you
but I think it's probably better to get
the guy who wrote the book regeneration
you know Paul Hawkin uh who you
interviewed in episode 627 and so I
figure we should just listen to him say
it yeah the goat I Define your
generation as putting life at the at
Center a very active decision I mean
that's what regeneration is and so
looking through that lens looking
through that you know that seeing the
world that way
then allows you to reflect you know on
what it is you're doing or what it is
that you're a part of this being done
and how it's being done and it doesn't
mean leaving it or quitting it it means
can we change that can we change that
and
um so regeneration is really not about
blaming and and and you know sort of uh
demonizing you know those institutions
or those economic sectors so much as
saying wait
can we just stop and go the other way
can we not regenerate the world and have
a GDP and an economy and jobs rather
than degenerate it and the fact is we
can so when we think about solving an
intractable problem like Global warmings
oh my God it's impossible what can we do
and
look all these Mega institutions and
political stupidity and ignorance and so
forth you know but if we step back
and say well what are the conditions
they create
self-organization or self-abnegation
that is the destroy that then that's
where we want to go
that is the source of change right so I
get the idea of regeneration in general
but how does regeneration apply to our
relationship with travel you know that's
a great question Rich which is why I
spoke with Amanda ho co-founder of the
regenerative Travel Group uh which is a
group of hotels on kind of what makes a
certain Resort a regenerative Resort and
what regenerative travel is and does
term
does not have been calling it that you
know they call it sustainability or
being green or Eco but we really believe
that you can't be regenerative if you're
not sustainable because you have to
actually go beyond sustainability to be
to be regenerative
um you know being green or Eco is doing
no harm
sustainability is reaching that neutral
but actually for generating and
restoring and replenishing a destination
or Community or ecosystem is going
beyond that threshold of just sustaining
simply sustaining something you know
extract extraction is going to a place
and you know kind of taking what you can
get you know from your experience or the
destination but really not giving back
to the community in any way so I think
regenive travel really goes beyond that
to
be more intentional and how you interact
with you know the ecosystem you go to
the people the locals and I think it's
coming with the mentality of wanting to
learn and also honor the sense of place
that you're going to um so I think that
really is kind of a fundamental part of
regeneration because it's really just
not about the ecosystem and
environmental aspect because all all
environmental and climate change issues
are as a result of peoples of as a
result of people and the pressures that
we're putting on the environment so at
the end of the day it really comes down
to the people
so that's why I needed to go to Playa
Viva because they are a resort that is
attempting to be regenerative so that
means among other things 100 off-grid
solar
no mini bar no air conditioning no
Instagram ready murals
although the Treehouse Bungalows are
stunning they're modeled after the Manta
and mobile arrays that are kind of
launched themselves offshore but what's
here is it's just raw nature and by that
I mean a virgin Beach like a real
completely virgin Beach
and the best mosquito net technology
ever deployed
while the resorts of Ixtapa and
Zihuatanejo are doing well again
play Viva isn't really in you fly into
ziwatanevo uh Ixtapa but that's not
where Playa Viva is it's on the coast
about an hour south
and these are pueblos not on the tourism
map at all we're talking about farming
towns where most of the food is exported
there are no grocery stores the men are
basically all gone they're in the city
they went North to the United States
it doesn't feel dangerous at all but it
does feel forgotten
and then after an hour we Veer off the
main Highway we enter this former
coconut palm and mango Farm where Playa
Viva exists and and is the opposite of
everything that's wrong with travel it
is the anti-tulum you know it is not
about the Flash and the glam
it's about the roots
um they it's right off an estuary they
have a
um permaculture farm that is producing
that is producing organic food for the
whole area oh yeah
these tomatoes look fabulous yes where's
the tomato plants a family bought it
David Leventhal and his wife
and her mother they bought it and have
decided and have used the hotel as a
vehicle to help in the education system
there help in the food system there
establishing this Organic Marketplace
and doing real development work it is
like akin to Peace Corps development
work where they're working with women
to develop things like Moringa and
turmeric and like these high value
crops that can fetch a lot in the
marketplace and can be grown in the
households uh garden and so that's the
kind of stuff they're doing it really is
peace corps-like stuff I've never heard
of it before of a hotel going that deep
with it right the difference being
between some kind of lip service green
washing kind of thing for PR purposes
versus true integration with the
community and a real
um kind of reimagining of the business
model that does just by you you know
virtue of operating contribute to the
community like it's so immersed in in
you know improving the the well-being of
the people that live there and and kind
of
um you know harvesting the best of
what's possible to contribute to the
betterment of that land and its populace
but also doing it in an economically
viable way that makes it
sustainable financially right and also
alluring for the adventure-minded you
know Eco tourists like yourself right
who's going to choose that kind of place
to patronize over you know whatever else
you know go into Puerto Vallarta or
whatever and it's south of Zihuatanejo
so Zee watching Idaho is famous for
Shawshank Redemption for where uh
um Andy Dufresne and red met up and
built a boat and lived happily ever
after
um but and it's a beautiful Town set a
set up on a bay but when I get there and
we get there we we drive in into this
through this Estuary where there's
actual crocodiles in the in the Estuary
there it's gorgeous
um you really feel like you've hit an
oasis and you get to the beach and they
have a mile of beachfront I think a
kilometer or a mile a beachfront that's
just it's a completely empty Beach there
is nothing else there and it's not about
um the party it's not about the kind of
Burning Man Vibes at all
so here is an example of of travel done
right and so that's how it looked and
you know to to get out in the ocean
there hump back whales dolphin pods you
know huge schools of big fish I saw a
barracuda amberjack I mean they they
warn you don't go in the water because
the waves but like it's a wild part of
Mexico that they are trying to bring
back
yeah and to do it in the right way in a
way that's that's uh also speaks to a
deeper kind of driver need or desire
within us
uh that is Seeking a more authentic
experience that's more grounded and more
kind of connected with the space and the
culture that that we're visiting
um that I feel and I I don't know this
is just like my projection perhaps but
it seems to me that this is on the
uptick like especially with young people
like do they want to go to some you know
I've been to some of those resorts in in
certain places across the world where it
takes you like a half an hour just to
like figure out where the beach is and
get out of the building right like or to
be on like some you know gigantic cruise
ship where it's almost impossible to
expose yourself to sunlight because it's
a floating ball like right to me all of
those things are insane and feel like
you know uh relics of a bygone era and
what I'm encouraged by or or optimistic
about is this enthusiasm or uh renewed
interest in these more grounded
experiences and patronizing places like
that that are more deeply connected with
their communities and not in a green
washing way but in a very real way are
contributing to the communities around
them yeah in a demonstrable way that is
not about like you know trying some
marketing plan that is like integral to
why they even exist in the first place
and then that's exactly what this place
is so I never even heard of anything
like it you know and uh we toured the
farm we uh hung out on the beach we
checked out the turtle Hatchery
um
and you know towards the end
when we first got there I mean listen
it's it takes when you're when you've
been in the city a long time you haven't
been on the road in a while and you get
escorted your room with no air
conditioning and 85 degree Heat at night
you know and the like the they have
great fans and all that and the insects
um you know it takes them in especially
with a toddler because we don't do that
too much you know I used to do that with
a backpack or just me and so with the
whole and April and I would do it
together but to have Zuma along it was
fascinating to watch him respond and his
response was pretty quick you know to be
the Comfort level in in on the beach the
Comfort level with the people I mean he
belongs in Mexico he loves it so much he
speaks Spanish so
um what I was left with kind of The
Parting experience was
um
was the last swim when I went out like
we we first we went and watched the the
turtles hatched and then walked down the
beach and try to dodge the Armada of
Seagulls I wanted to eat them and turns
and then we then I went out for a swim
and it was in this kind of there was the
bioluminescence in the water so these
stinging little blue things and it's you
like looking down it was kind of green
water because they had the
bioluminescence and and you just see
like sparkling blue everywhere and
Diving down and you hear the whale song
like it's like right next to you like uh
like just just just booming whale song
and those are the kinds of things you
come up and you're like
yeah
that's why you travel
you know we've been talking about
regenerative travel in terms of what you
can do as a traveler to help a
particular destination or to contribute
to a particular destination but
I mean this is why we do it to
regenerate ourselves amidst the ultimate
regeneration I mean that's why I've
always been interested in going to new
places new countries meet new people
learn languages
because it's a shedding of your skin
that allows us to you know tap into the
Oneness of everything
yeah that's beautiful yeah
um what an amazing experience and also
to be able to share that with Zuma at
such a formative age you know and I feel
like that's a situation or or a uh you
know a place
um an organization that is figured out
how to how to
um create and share that experience and
do it in a way that gives back to the
culture that regenerates the environment
that is sustainable in its practices and
I feel like we need to
really figure out how to scale up these
new business plans and create incentives
for the tourism industry at large such
that that is the more attractive
um option or lure for the Curious
traveler as opposed to the traditional
you know kind of Hotel experience right
because I think consumers if given the
choice
um are going to opt for this type of
experience over that more conventional
type well right I mean you know let's be
honest though like there is a it's not
the Comfort based travel so not it's
right it's not going to be necessarily
for everyone and play Aviva's approach
is to not only restore their land but
also to take a watershed approach so
that the idea is to actually help
upstream and help the families and
Farmers that live all the way up in the
mountains above which you can see from
the beach and and and any anybody on the
river that feeds their Estuary is their
responsibility in terms of approaching
them getting buy-in from them trying to
help uh in a way that can be beneficial
to the Watershed and to everybody
involved and so that is like you say a
special scope of work you know not
everyone's going to take that on and
even Playa viva's own even though
they've done a lot of great work you
can't say that you know development work
takes a long time and you can't say
they've restored that entire Watershed
sure they've restored their part of it
um you know Watershed restoration is a
whole is a huge task and they're on that
journey and coming back from Mexico you
know it was funny because before going
to Mexico I was so hungry for it I was
so like you know we we joke with the
Apocalypse Now intro but like I was
[__] desperate for it I need to go up
River I am Martin Sheen I am going to
find Colonel Kurtz and he's going to
answer my questions I need an admission
and Rich gave me one I need a bald man
halfway submerged in the water who's
mysterious and I need uh it you know I
need a guy shooting a gun off like I
needed it but coming back it's the
Dennis Hopper character in this
narrative uh Zuma okay
um but then coming back you know to
soggy California from the Sun again
uh it wasn't necessarily like more crap
travel I craved actually it was like the
idea of watershed restoration just kept
peeing and
you know what I wanted was a deeper
connection to my own watershed
that's what I wanted you know that's
what I left that place with and I think
that's interesting because I didn't
anticipate that like that's that idea of
like you have to go away uh in order to
realize that everything you were looking
for is like in your backyard the whole
time right because because we don't look
at the world I mean we should Define
watershed and I talked to him I met
MacMillan who runs a nonprofit called
wild places who I used to work with a
tree people and he that's that's what he
does is watershed restoration and and he
could better Define what that is and and
why it's important
you can think of a watershed as a
bathtub almost and and the sides of the
bathtub or the the the edges of the
mountain where water falls and drains
down towards the bottom where it lands
into a river or a stream and makes its
way to the ocean
um
so okay yeah so that's basically a
pretty simplified understanding of what
a watershed is uh it's you know an area
of land and water that captures the
precipitation that comes out of the sky
and funnels it into a particular body of
water like a stream or a river
um and watersheds come in all sizes and
they're located everywhere we're all
living in a watershed and I think that
it it's it's important that folks
understand that even under the concrete
Nas fault there were streams and Lake
beds and rivers that occupied those
spaces and still do just not as visible
to us you know those watersheds and that
surface waters lead to the recharging of
our aquifers which is where our drinking
water essentially comes from so it's
important to recognize that we're all in
a watershed
that's what I wanted I wanted to I
wanted to go to my own Creeks I wanted
to watch that flow out to the ocean I
wanted to see how that how you know you
where you live I mean that that's got to
be a primary you must see it in all
right in yeah in uh in Malibu Creek yeah
yeah it's like raging right yeah it's
amazing it is amazing yeah and to
connect to it in a real way
um is something that I'd encourage
everyone to do and to find your
Watershed and to and to explore it and
to connect with it because it's like we
don't look at the world that way but
that's all the way the world is made up
it's kind of the way
indigenous communities were founded
around the water and and and respecting
that water source because they had to
we're so disconnected from all of that
going to Playa Viva and seeing that
restoration and process it really kind
of inspired me to to connect again to
that that idea
where does all of this leave us is
travel the great equalizer does it build
Bridges or is it breeding more
inequality and discontent and
environmental degradation I mean what is
The Travelers responsibility in terms of
carbon footprint
and cultural awareness is it all uh get
what you can well you can sort of
free-for-all kind of thing or
how can we continue to explore the Earth
while also walking more gently upon it
hmm
you know I think there's a few Concepts
that kind of jotted down when we were
talking about we're thinking about this
because obviously whenever we now we've
done two of these there's no clear
answers right I mean that's why we chose
these interesting topics because they're
not topics that are easily parsed down
to a black and white
um they're really there really is Nuance
in all of this but one thing I thought
of was Killian's concept of once a year
maybe International otherwise staying
you know closer to home and so that
means local travel I mean you don't have
to go far like you could travel
exploring your own City could be could
be fun you can you can treat you can be
a guest in your own town you can explore
a new neighborhood you can connect to
your own Watershed which I think is a
great way of of traveling so that's one
yeah and we talked a little bit earlier
about the fact that
um for the most part you travel to
certain places and you're kind of in and
out but perhaps you can rewrite that you
know narrative and find a way to be more
immersive you know in the community uh
and and contribute so that when you
leave you feel like you've left it a
little bit better than uh when you
arrived yeah I mean that's a key Killian
concept is if you're going to go to the
trouble of getting on the plane and
doing the and and being part of that
footprint then make sure it counts don't
just go in and out don't just maybe
don't do like Killian's not doing a a
race that he has to go in and out of I
mean and he's the best so maybe you pick
your spots
um
also in terms of carbon offsets uh I
thought about this a lot I personally
wouldn't use any of those services not
because I think they're all bad
um but because I'm kind of picky with
the charitable donations I want to give
to and I want to give them to places
that I feel like are doing great work
and so that means I want a personal
engagement with them
and talking about Watershed stuff really
got me thinking like you know a Mets
organization is one option but as he
mentioned every Watershed is going to
have some organization associated with
it that means every place is going to
have a watershed group so I would
encourage you to look for yours and
maybe fund their work
um unless something's alarming about it
but if you're going to fund
environmental work that's restorative
including tree planting you know stream
bed restoration that kind of stuff then
why not make it local and then every
time you do a trip
use that carbon offset formula if it's
12 bucks for a six hour flight if it's
50 bucks for a transcontinental fly then
that's what you give to your local group
but you can do both right yeah like it
would be good to purchase those carbon
offsets and
figure out how to you know contribute in
a more immersive way yeah in the place
that you're visiting and I think it
would be beneficial to have a list of
links or you know potential
possibilities for that contribution in
the show notes to the podcast so we'll
try to compile that we'll do that yeah
that means you Adam put that together
for us I knew I sensed it yeah right you
got it
um
you know and I think just in closing you
know it's it is such a curious thing
because you know I love travel you love
travel like I I do I am looking forward
to the travel upon us
um but I think the travel that has meant
the most to to me has been the the the
experiences that are more immersive and
then rethinking
that
um
that quality of immersion
isn't necessarily Tethered to an exotic
location like the dark Retreats come to
mind which we've talked about right like
going into a cave like you want doesn't
[__] matter where that cave is right
you're in the dark right do you want to
build that cave in your backyard I guess
if you wanted to and create your own
dark retreat but I think what's cool
about that is that it's creating a
conversation around
um
you know the the the caliber and the
quality and the intentionality of the
experiences we want to have with our
precious free time as opposed to going
to you know the all-inclusive Buffet
whatever right like I'm gonna go into
the dark and like go Inward and learn
something about myself to become you
know a a more self self-actualized
person a better human whatever so that I
can have uh you know a more fulfilling
life like that's cool I think there's a
lot of young people who are more
interested in in that kind of experience
which which is you know not something
that like when I was in my 20s people
were thinking about which leaves me very
encouraged and optimistic about the
future and uh to the extent that we can
create
systems and incentives and you know kind
of political economic will and and
receptivity like we were talking about
earlier around that I think that we're
in a good place of creating a situation
in which we are building
better travel experiences that are truly
regenerative and not regenerative in
just name only
I think at the end of the day I think
people are never going to stop traveling
um so I think it's more important to
actually really consider how you're
traveling what businesses you're
supporting when you travel because I
think you can actually make a much
bigger impact by being more intentional
and selective about how you're actually
going to impact the destination on on
these decisions you make
my best experiences are always staying
in small locally run places where you
have a lot of contact with the owners
who usually have their heart and soul in
the place it's how they make their
living that helps you have interactions
with the village you understand what's
going on your money is going directly to
them you know if there's some way that
you can help out you might be able to
help out a single person you might be
able to you know it's it's kind of the
smaller you go the more impact you're
making in a positive way
idea of regeneration the core of it is
to experience the inseparability
of everything
[Music]
thanks to Amanda Harris Amanda ho
Celeste Brash Hugh Garvey Killian jornay
Mehmet McMillan Paul Feinstein Robbie
Ballinger and Paul Hawkins and of course
everybody here at the studio Jason
camiolo and Drake and everybody here who
helped make this show possible
is that include me or no
do I is that you thank you is this
unfair Talent no
you don't need to be recognized you're
the one [__] talking the whole time
did you thank me why didn't you thank me